I'll go impressed my name is planar all
right welcome back to another episode
[Music]
okay no malevolence right
to do
one
to
I don't want okay straight what do I win
what do I win
always so I can go in there this is just
like a
security thingamajigger
[Music]
there we go what the [ __ ] was that all
about what was he doing in that thing
why goat why why almighty goat I thought
we were cool okay mute we are alive I
don't know how I will know why yesterday
you told me about the pig a pie and all
that I can't see it's that's not lemon
tree I'm turning my head up and down
[Music]
turn it turn it turn it turn it
invisible glass amazing technology
not you again okay okay I'm you
[Music]
hello
[Music]
another suite as argued that I missed
[Music]
that's [ __ ] hot
damn
[Music]
excuse me lady your kid is out it's
funny to let you know
[Music]
Hey
big banner dis except that hello
bathroom
no secrets well I'll be going then thank
you very much ah wonderful wonderful
wonderful one
[Music]
morning
fueling comes revival a volatile
chemicals are news these materials are
highly corrosive wear protection I will
you can tell me what to do
piggies yeah yeah - yeah how you doing
[ __ ] kiss me ah have you seen my big
brother Pierce he is damn sexy I tell
you oh man you got to make out with him
he wants you to make out with you oh so
sexy I rub it all over the wall yeah
alright I'll leave you there boots hey
Paris
alright truck the link tag thingy
well I guess we're going here
yeah yeah whoa nice touch it pimps make
a smack yeah ain't no pun like a that's
nice that window looks a bit suspicious
hi guys
so yeah whoa don't close on me that moon
is [ __ ] small
I note thank you come on papa let's
climb this one I can see more pictures
at the top
[Music]
[Music]
it's my lantern breaking no wait why
don't break on me lantee looter come on
come on come on hey stop winking what is
this place exactly thank Dunstan's
Church oh you sneaky son of a [ __ ] god
I hate you I think I will have like an
intense sir like I know there's like
fear of spiders and then I reckon a
phobia and stuff like that I wonder if
there's like feral pigs or some [ __ ]
like that I bet there is that a button I
bet there will be after this game good
anyway okay we didn't really explore
over here I think we came out from there
and I'm like what's over here
there's some potatoes I think there
could be I would love me some potatoes
everyone loves potatoes that's what my
mom said it's if you ever have the
chance you will marry a potato and make
me proud
whatever you say hey thanks yay
all right get my I've seen their pits oh
that feels good
all right let me tweak tips look at the
trike you like my twerking Pierce you're
lucky when I make ugh vibrate bend it
over here you make somebody shake you're
lucky we're not making a it's fine
Braden look at working with the battle
pits yeah
god damn it need to focus
am I right guys you're lucky we're not
worth it what we're not working god damn
it stop it seriously honey trying to
progress Oh jack
now boy you're smart okay I don't know
how I don't know why but that was I
didn't think they'd make you like suck
it
I didn't think they'd make you go all
the way that's what she said I didn't
know
watch what am i doing
begging yo shopping what keep spinning
keep spinning keep spinning keep
spinning can't spin again spin again
spin again spinning keep spinning get
ready
[Applause]
dr. Park and we'll close the windows
even I am a polite little Shepherd ebook
stoppin for that's what I have
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh that's what I am that's
what you are tilt you back girl
you go girl I am filled with joy [ __ ]
you're smart and [ __ ] you piggy groups
what do I do now what do I do now
what's the on button Java yes inato
bonauto why did I do this I thought you
were fine oh okay yeah you got to spin
that [ __ ] spin that [ __ ] Dee JPL's
[Applause]
you're a car I get it and now we can go
in here why climb over when you can
solve Papa Schatzi can we take your home
yes my dad of course we can take it home
pigs on hats I think why don't have you
targetable I'll be going here no okay
what interesting
all right well done down oh whoa whoa
whoa
this looks great can't wait to see
what's in there oh [ __ ] man man man oh
man oh man oh man man oh man oh man okay
we're in this kind of church churches
aren't that bad you know that make me
feel safe
yes indeed indeed I don't dance uh my
face yeah okay okay I look away one
second you're already making out I hate
you so much why do you do this to me
alright it's a left side I think it
doesn't matter I think I can go wherever
I please and I think Jesus is here and
that makes me happy
no more pigs no more pain thanks don't
squeal like that I'm pretty sure
hello Matt whoa oh nice yeah yeah
hey Jesus I guess so I did came to check
this place out
check out
[Music]
and again
cool very cool
what I knew it I know it
God is that you all the hell's at my
tipping oh my god and his twerking
abilities it all makes sense
it all makes sense I whoa what is that
cat doing over the pig how dare they
piggies are awesome anyway sorry I can't
say all day got [ __ ] to be done and that
is on the toilet where's the bathroom
sorry I'm trying to Hey
okay
[Music]
let's add a puzzle or was that just a
coincidence it's goddamn I'm smart I
like how I solved every [ __ ] puzzle
by just randomly approaching things I
think this door should be open now no we
are looking for there you are
where the hell were you you son of a
[ __ ] okay well we did it we are so
smart
you and I ow Thanks
don't mind me just gonna put this in
there jump BAM
nice teleportation skills and that of
course opens magic all right
excelsior pax El Cid [ __ ] are very
bad oh that is don't see you later
piggies oh wow wow wow hey whoa
okay keeps going down wonderful
okay
it's happening potatoes do it you can
hear the sea shut up
not interested why do you oh not now
lantern not now please
hang in there lanty looter what is this
[Applause]
what was that
I didn't hear a police [ __ ]
[Music]
I hear voices
chorus yeah in China speak Swedish
another cliffhanger ending I know you
like it a little bit
gotta cover today all right
I kept messing
[Music]
you